BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Hello everyone!
Let me introduce myself first. My name is Ben. This is the one shown on the slide.
We are very happy to share with you.
A variety of great services from Google Play
These services can help you
Successfully expand the game business on Play
We announced an exciting news when we opened earlier today.
That is, we canceled the 50MB limit.
Now we increase the limit to 100MB
The era of 50MB cap is over
Long live 100MB!
There is no doubt that this is a long time
The most urgent request of everyone
So I think we can’t stress this anymore.
JOHN MCGUIRE: Yes, thank you Ben.
Hello everyone
I am John McGuire.
Is a member of the Google Play business development team
I also feel that this news is exciting.
Thank you very much for your tolerance of the 50MB limit.
We have a lot on the scene... Oh, yes, I need this...
We have a lot of game developers on site.
I want to make a small investigation first.
See how many of you have made mobile games
If you have made it, please raise your hand.
It seems that almost everyone has ever made it.
I feel that people who make mobile games are very simple, please continue to raise your hand.
Let me see
Ok
Only one or two people raised their hands
Well, making mobile games is not easy
I have done it myself.
I want to introduce to you below.
The five stages we experienced while making the game
And what help can Play do for you?
The first is the concept stage
This is the most interesting stage
You may need a meeting room, some pizza
There is also a bunch of sticky notes
Finally came up with a really good idea.
Such as "Zombie Match 3" card battle game
Soon you will need to decide
According to which idea to design the prototype
You will hope as soon as possible
Let your game run on your device
Main work in the prototype design phase
Is constantly improving
See how fast you can improve your game based on feedback
Make the game more perfect
Next, when you are ready
Realize some key performance indicators (KPI) through the game
You can enter the trial release stage
Then you need to select one or more regions.
Then start experimenting with your game to get KPIs.
Understand how the market reacts to your game
Finally, when you decide to release the game
At such an important moment
You need to hang your appetite as much as possible
You can prepare a bunch of champagne and hold a series of celebrations.
Let everyone have a drink together
In fact, this is relatively easy
Because next, you have to let the game go online.
This is the toughest
Today we are here to introduce to you.
How can Play play in these stages?
Help you
At the moment, we can’t help you at the concept stage.
But maybe one day we can help with this.
For Alpha/Beta testing
Earlier today, Ellie has introduced the Alpha/Beta test.
This is a feature in the Developer Console
With this feature, you can upload APK
And upload it to Alpha or Beta
This feature has two important features
One is that users must choose to participate.
Alpha or Beta test
The second is that users cannot post reviews.
So when your game is in the prototyping phase
This is really a good way
Allows you to quickly and easily improve the game
And will not have a negative impact due to problems or minor errors in the game.
Second, Alpha or Beta testing can be open or closed.
This is the feature we introduced a few months ago.
I remember it was two months ago.
If you choose closed test
You may need to email
Invite a group of trusted testers
You must first invite them to accept the invitation
You can join your test team
Open beta test, or open alpha test, whichever is the kind
In fact, all get a URL first.
Then you can distribute the URL
Anyone with this URL can download and play your game
I recall the scene when I was making the game in 2012.
That was a long time ago, when we didn't have this test function.
If you have one, this feature will be very practical.
I will plan to use this feature like this.
I will first conduct a closed beta test.
Invite friends and family as testers
Maybe also invite colleagues from our game team.
Then I will go through the open beta test again.
In order to pass the wider population
Gather more relevant feedback
There are many ways to distribute games.
For example, if you have relevant marketing channels
You can distribute the URL through this channel.
I think the Alpha/Beta test is really a great feature.
We will always use this feature during game development.
Next, you are ready to try to release the game.
Trial is a very important stage
Because this is the first time for consumers
Really see your game
We have developed related functions
Can help you optimize your game during the trial release
This feature is called a store listing experiment.
Explain to everyone
Product details experimental solutions currently available on the market
very expensive
And there are also some shortcomings
You can see that this is a citation from Rovio.
They spent $50,000 on testing for more than six months.
Mainly tested the game's icon and description
This solution is not perfect
We want to continue to improve
So we launched the store listing experiment feature a few months ago.
You can use this feature to test your game’s icons, videos, and images.
And a short description and detailed description
I just said
Trial is the consumer in the market
The first time I really saw your game
When your game is in the trial release phase
You might want to test something like icons
Because icons are actually the most visible content for consumers.
Also during your development process
One aspect that needs to be considered the most
Here is an example for everyone.
Is the developer of our cooperation with Kongregate
You can see that during the trial release phase
They have optimized or tested their game icons
After that, their display volume per display increased by 91%.
Everyone can think about this effect.
Only need to make such improvements
Can effectively control
Cost per installation
BENJAMIN FRENKEL: When I look at these things
I can't predict it at all.
Which icon might work best?
Is Mr. Eyepatch?
Will its effect be the best?
Still the girl with the gun?
Is that red-haired girl? Still this helicopter?
Nobody knows
We can't know the answer
JOHN MCGUIRE: Yes.
That's right
This is also our recommendation for everyone
a best practice used during the trial release
That is, optimize for content with unknown effects
For example, which icon can well resonate with the player.
Next, you decide to officially release the game.
This is a very important moment
We hope to help you as much as possible
Hanging the appetite of consumers
So we were a few months ago
Developed a product called pre-registration
I am a big fan of Arnold Schwarzenegger.
A new movie was released this summer.
Named Terminator: Genesis
Arno played two roles in 1984 and 2014.
Developer Glu made a
Games related to this movie
I visited the marketing page they made.
Click the "Click here to pre-register" button
I entered their store.
On the store page I saw a big green invitation button
It says "Click here to pre-register"
I received a notification after clicking
Which reads: Hey! We will send you a push notification when the game is released.
Tell you that we have officially released the game
I really like this way.
I clicked "OK"
I know
Then I scroll down the page
You can see a series of videos of the explosion, some marketing materials.
And other similar content
I can also share this game with my friends.
And see what other games the developer has made.
Everyone is usually busy.
So sometimes I forget the specific release time.
However, I have not forgotten this game.
I received a push notification after the game was released.
Which reads: Hey! The game has been officially released
Come and play!
I clicked on the push notification
Then I entered the store and started playing the game.
We believe pre-registration is a very important feature
Can hang out the appetite of consumers for your game
If everyone is interested in this feature
Can consult your business development manager
These are the whole process from initial idea to game release.
Next, Ben will introduce you.
Content related to the online operation of the game
See if you can continue -- hey, you can.
BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Ok.
As John said before, everyone has officially released the game so far.
Has put the game on the market
Need to think now
How to make the game just released
Great success on Play
I am in the Play Games Service Team
As product manager
The mission of the Play Games Services team is to help customers make this transition happen smoothly.
Make your business grow and build a successful game
And the direction we have to work on is
Provide a way for relevant people and developers
Enable them to design new goals that keep players excited
In addition to the core game
Give players some new experiences
Such as achievements, leaderboards, player analysis
Tasks, multiplayer games, etc.
All these different services together form a cohesive product
Such products can achieve greater success.
Mention the goals we have to work hard
That is the core task of our Play Games service team.
I want to revolve around the story of Eric Froemling
To specify
Eric is what we want to play through Play Games
Typical developer for their help
He is a team alone
All the work related to the game
He is an artist
Animator
game designer
At the same time, I have to be responsible for the user to get all the things that are basically done by him alone.
But for Eric, to be successful
He needs to bring this business
Provided to the player as a continuous service
And the huge challenge he faces is
Compete with the largest possible game developer
And such developers are equipped with many data analysis experts and developers.
And artist
So our task is to get Eric
Ability to compete with large game developers
This is what our Play Games Services team is trying to do.
Our initial thought was
Want to provide developers with
Data analysis required to conduct business
This is what we did earlier this year.
Reasons for launching the Player Analytics tool
Player Analytics is a set of reports in the Developer Console
Allows you to understand
Everything that happens in the game
This is a good example
We have provided developers with
Source/Sink report
When organizing GDC earlier this year
We stayed with Eric for a long time.
Produced a large number of different report samples
To test the effects of various ideas
We have seen the analysis data
Share these reports to Eric
We found that the game was economically released after the release.
There is a serious imbalance problem
This is a typical problem
Too many games distributed
These game tokens are in the game
But not fully used
Here he uses the game token
The speed at which he distributes tokens is amazing.
Eventually leading to the game
Almost impossible
The moment when the player needs to make an in-app purchase
Therefore, we gave him this report.
He quickly understood
Need to make some improvements to the current situation
Then he made some changes to the game.
Immediately there was an immediate effect
The positions of these two lines are exchanged.
This blue line representing "sink"
For the first time, he exceeded him in the game.
Speed ​​of distributing tokens
This is a huge turning point for him.
Just three weeks later
The average annual revenue of each active user has more than doubled
The average revenue per paying user has increased by nearly 70%
Produce such a big impact in such a short period of time
Almost unheard of
We will continue to work hard to provide more reports.
Bring more value to everyone
In particular, Eric said such a passage.
"Player Analysis" helped me to understand the shortcomings of BombSquad
Indicated the correct direction of improvement
Let me create the game I want.
And got the ideal income"
We will continue to work hard in this area
Provide new features for everyone
Just recently, we launched
"Time Series Browser"
Time series browser is a report
Can help you understand
What happens at the most critical moment of the game
What happened when the player first started playing the game?
What happened before the player left the game?
You can use this report to compare
Different player types
You can compare players who spend more in the game.
Players who spend less in the game
And the dynamics of players who have never spent in the game
In this way, you can accurately understand some details.
For example, let's take a look at the third line here, which is player number 3.
The player spent $4.99 in the game.
And before that, we can see
The player has won several different achievements
Hover your mouse over each graphic
You can learn more about the specific situation.
Let me introduce you to the background information here.
Everyone can see
Each line here represents a player
You can use this line to learn about all the events that the player has played during the game.
We collect all the time series every day.
Then pick a sample from it and give it to you.
So you can get to know more
What happened in the game
Intuitively understand what works well and which content is not performing well
We also plan to add some presets to this report.
These configurations can answer specific types of questions
For example, you can choose to ask a question
What happened when the player started playing the game?
At what stage of the game is the player lost?
Is the tutorial not good?
You can also ask questions like this before the player spends their first time?
You can see the player’s first cost here.
And all we do is align all the first cost events
Look to the left
You can see all the things that happen before the player spends their first time.
And looking to the right
You can see everything that happens after the player’s first spend.
You can compare different player types
As I said before
So that you can understand intuitively
Which content in the game works well
Those who spend more, what is their buying power?
And why some players are in the game
Very little cost
Of course, you still need to understand
Why are players leaving your game?
We also provided another pre-configured report.
Allows you to target players who have lost in the past 28 days
Align all the activities they left when you left the game
You can easily view to the left
Understand what caused this result
Is it because players often lose in tournament mode?
Do I need to improve the matchmaking mechanism?
You can use this report to understand everything
We also offer a set of custom activities
You can also add to the report
So, except for all the default content
Understand player’s spending, achievements, and conversations
You can also record your own custom activities
Whether you want to visualize any information in this report
Can be done by adding an event to the game
To achieve this goal easily
On the second day
You will be able to view specific data streams from this report.
And you can get to know more
The specific type of data you need
In addition, we also launched the "Activity Viewer"
It is a universal activity visualization tool
Tell us about the background information here.
We partnered with Eric before the Game Developers Conference earlier this year.
In the prototyping phase
We used a commercial BI product
You may also need to buy this product.
We collected all the raw activity data
Then enter all the data into this commercial BI tool
Then basically generated a prototype of all the reports
However, just in the process
We understand what is the key information and what types of reports
What types of visualization data
Is really important
We pick out the prototyping phase of the player analysis
All use cases found
We will take all these key use cases
Are applied to this product
In this way, the event viewer
Can be used in this very expensive commercial BI product
Get all the significant data
Then we provide this data for free in the Developer Console.
So that developers can integrate Play Games services.
But only analyzing the data is not enough
We are very satisfied with the analysis data.
We provide you with the most comprehensive and analytical data in the world.
But you must be able to really take action in the game
To get the core metrics in your KPI
it has been improved
So we launched the "Tasks" feature.
The task is for players across your entire community
Set time-sensitive goals
A task like this game is a typical example.
This is the game "TowerMadness 2" developed by our partner Limbic.
They designed a weekend mission
Every weekend, players will see the mission in the game app.
This is similar to the companion application for all of these services.
The system will display the tasks that need to be completed.
Players can accept tasks and join the game
Complete the task in the game
Earn the reward in this game, which is wool.
This is after you release the game
A great way to attract players to play games again
No need for players to update to get new APKs
Provide content in a dynamic manner
This point is very important
Helps you apply analytical data to the action phase
Next I will introduce a short case study.
This case comes from our partner Concrete Software
This company has been in business for several years.
The team has about 10 to 15 people, mostly engineers.
They spend an extra minute each time dealing with the server infrastructure
And working online
Time available for engaging in your favorite game development work
Less
So through the "task" function
They have the opportunity to have the capacity of a large company
Without a huge server infrastructure
And other types of support
They got the service for free
Let them have time to invest in the game production work they love.
This is their most successful game "PBA Bowling"
John, are you bowling?
JOHN MCGUIRE: I played very badly.
But I still enjoy it.
BENJAMIN FRENKEL: In PBA Bowling
Everyone can be a bowling superstar
Get a sense of accomplishment
They use the "task" function to get rid of
Properly follow all our best practices
In this use case
What makes people feel particularly excited is
The way they will provide players with new content
As an important part of the game
Take a look at this example.
This is the calendar of promotional events in January this year.
Everyone can see
They provide new content to players multiple times a week.
For example, on January 7, they launched the "Hammer Black Widow Legend" bowling
This is a great bowling
To be honest, it’s awesome.
In addition to launching new bowling balls
They also advertise in the game
Push notification
Post information using social media like Twitter
And every time they launch new content
Will launch a task at the same time
And they are going to task
As an important part of the online operations strategy
Because it’s about user engagement.
Produce measurable substantive impact
They found out after observing the data.
On the day the player's mission is accepted
The number of sessions per player is 15% higher than the benchmark
And this effect is very long lasting
The player’s session count is still 4% higher than the benchmark after completing the task
So everyone can understand
Why do they want to provide new content to the player?
Think of the task as a core part
Next we will continue to discuss this topic
How to use the player statistics API for data analysis
Player Statistics API is our most recent
With the latest version of the Play Services SDK
New features introduced together
It can help you
Find out which segment of the player is located
Let me give you an example.
Suppose a player initiates a conversation in your game.
The player has already logged into the game
You can call the player statistics API
Found that the user's spending power in the game is in the 95th percentile
You also found that the user has not logged in to the game for 10 days.
At this point you can show the user a passionate promotional message.
It says: Welcome back!
We have prepared some gold coins for you.
You can buy some good things in the game.
Therefore, important player statistics
Allows you to segment each player group
Provide a tailored experience
And you can learn about it
For example, the percentile of the player's session, the duration of the session, etc.
We will continue to aggregate these statistics into this API.
I believe this will bring you
Great value
There is another good example
Suppose you want to motivate your ads
Earn revenue from players
Now this is a very common pattern
We have some partners with up to 50% of the revenue
Is from such incentive ads
However, maybe you don't want it
Show incentive ads to all players
For players who can never spend in the game
You may not want to run this type of ad.
Let's assume again that there is a player logging in to the game and you called the API.
You find that the player’s spending power is at the lower percentile
But the interaction with the game is very high
This type of player is right for you.
Object of this special option
We have already discussed
How does Play go through various methods?
Create value throughout the life of the game
But to build a good, successful game
Still very, very difficult
However, take advantage of the services John has just introduced.
Reintegrate Play Game Services
Everyone can take the first step towards success
Now we have a question and answer session at our site. Do you have any questions?
I seem to see someone raising her hand.
Audience: You mentioned
Ability to see when users are losing
Is this defined by the developer?
Or is it preset by the Google Player Analytics tool?
BENJAMIN FRENKEL: You are asking us how to define user churn?
Audience: Yes
BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Ok.
His question is how do we define user churn?
This is the indicator we set for everyone.
But it has a standard formula
If a player has not logged in to the game for 7 days
We will classify the player as a lost player.
And traced back to the last day the user played the game, which is his last activity in the game.
Audience: If I want to be in my game
Adjust this period to 10 or 14 days
Can I change it?
BENJAMIN FRENKEL: Not working now.
But this is why we invite everyone to come here.
This is a great feedback
Everyone is welcome to drink beer at the time of the arranged drink.
We can talk
How to modify the definition of user churn
Audience: Thank you!
[play music]